ce soir nous en disant qu'ils sont
consacrés à josé garcia l'occasion du
film pars vite et reviens tard de régis
wargnier film tiré du livre de fred
vargas du même titre
josé garcia bonsoir alors on m'a dit que
vous avez fait l'école du cirque
c'est vrai ça j'ai fait un petit passage
à l'école du ciel quoi je voulais voir
comment les gens travailler là bas et je
n'ai pas fait tout là toute la scolarité
pas eu cette chance mais mais c'est
passionnant mais on est resté quelque
chose un petit goût de funambule un peu
sur les funambules non mais il en est
resté en tout cas une ag j'ai compris
qu'il fallait que je prenne un peu plus
en main mon métier d'acteur quand j'ai
vu les gens du siècle travailler quoi
c'est ça qui est parce que vous avez la
réputation est un bosseur un super
bosseur et de travailler les rôles et là
il ya un rôle il fallait entrer dedans
vous étiez attendu pour en sortir et en
sortir wayne presque là bas justement
quand on est entré dans la rolls comme
celui-là c'est adam verte tient le rôle
d'un personnage qui était très attendue
puisque le livre de fred vargas est un
énorme succès le personnage était
quasiment mythique
oui mais quand on rentre dedans on a
tendu un faux nom c'est vrai que je
m'étais pas rendu compte à cannes à quel
point fred vargas avait des femmes
jockeys
il y en a beaucoup qui sont derrière on
va reparler très de bargas et donc on va
parler de ce parent vite et reviens tard
le sujet de ce film
comment comment dire on est dans paris
on est paris paris d'aujourd'hui et sur
des portes on dessine ce ce symbole qui
est 1,4 à l'envers qui est en fait le
signe de croix quand on lève pas la main
que se passe-t-il
et on voit apparaître des canards qui
ont toutes les stigmates de la peste
noire
est ce que c'est le retour de la peste
noire à paris et donc vous êtes appelés
vous êtes adamsberg et qu'est ce qui va
se passer ensuite
on regarde d'abord la bande annonce du
film
d'autre part vite et reviens tard et on
expliquera le titre du film après
la marque à la 4e place et aura le cas
arbaud et surtout fameux pour sa valeur
de talisman contre la peste la mort noir
quelques annonce un retour de la pause
sylvain marveaux on a interrogé leurs
familles ocarian ne dit pas forcément
illogique qu'ils en auto sud si les
causes de décès reste mystérieusement
évoqué les risques de contamination dans
l'erreur de nous rappeler protéger
personne quand les animaux qui vivent
dans la profondeur de dernis italie
abandonnent leur habitat naturel
quelque chose est en marche et qui va
bientôt émerger
c'est super oka
donc je suis si j'entends vos supporter
inventé vos intuitions si génial
tellement hors norme
[Applaudissements]
au sortir
[Musique]
alors le titre c'était par vide reste
longtemps et revient vers sa oui parce
que la peste
c'était ce qu'on disait aux gens qui est
qui et quand un village été touchée par
la peste pour qu'il s'en aille le plus
loin possible et qui reviennent jamais
est-ce que vous connaissiez fred vargas
avant non on est en pleine journée pas
rencontrée elle est comme ça allait très
mystérieux mais je sais très bien moi je
trouve que c'est formidable aussi de
laisser son oeuvre c'est sa preuve alors
je crois que vous êtes à l'approché de
fred vargas par le premier l'homme aux
cercles au cercle bleu voyez
l'apparition du commissaire adamsberg
oeil dans l'oeuf de fred
donc quand on tombe sur un quand on
tombe sur un livre comme ça on se dit je
vais jouer parce que là c'était c'était
sur comment on pratique très difficile
parce qu en fait je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi j'ai ce dernier avait fait
appel à moi
c'est vrai que quand on lit et qu'on
pense qu on a du mal à mettre un visage
sur cet homme on a du mal à savoir
comment il est habillé donc chacun c'est
la force de ce livre c'est que chacun un
peut s'inventer un personnage qui lui
est propre
donc la grosse angoisse quand on m'a
présenté le film là maintenant aux
provinces je me suis dit on va se battre
contre un imaginaire parce que la moitié
de la salle la lune et ils viennent voir
le film pour voir juste avant aussi et
jusqu'à maintenant c'est assez génial
parce qu'on a eu que des bonnes
surprises
c'est là que je pense que les gens qui
aiment bien fred vargas aime bien se
faire enfin être transporté dans une
atmosphère et s'il ya une chose qui est
resté parce qu'évidemment une adaptation
c'est toujours délicat au cinéma c'est
de préserver un rythme une atmosphère
par rapport au lit alors les nos
mémoires de zinc donc quatre rubriques
pour en savoir plus sur josé garcia
d'aller chercher un petit peu dans les
quoi la première rubrique punching ball
on va vous demander de te traiter un
sujet d'actualité que un petit peu
énervé alors notre putching ball bien
évidemment nous avons un petit bol
alors quels sujets vous avez choisi
envie de alors le sujet mais c'était
cette histoire de louvres bis abouti à
dubai la wii mais ben oui parce que
c'est intéressant de type olivier l'idée
c'est que on va un peu franchisés le
lourd donc on va prêter nos collections
de façon à exister un petit peu partout
dans le monde comme le guggenheim le
fait oui oui même new york
oui il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de musées
même mois le christ qui nous énerve loeb
a écouté je suis pas énervé par là par
l'association ce que je trouve que il ya
tellement d'oeuvre qu'on ne verra pas et
qui sont cachés au look que je trouve
que c'est formidable qu'un qu'un musée
je vous les donne ou prêtes ou en tout
cas face faire le tour du monde de
toutes ces oeuvres qu'on n'a pas
l'occasion de voir mais évidemment c'est
bien de pouvoir le faire et des pays
riches là et de leur louer en
l'occurrence le cas mais l'idée c'est si
on fait ça ça serait bien aussi de
pouvoir donner à des pics sont plus
pauvres
je comprends l'opportunité avec cet
argent de pouvoir leur offrir des
moments
de beauté oui mais vous avez le
sentiment que c'est pas tout à fait ça
qu'on nous prépare pas écouté je ne sais
pas si c'est ça qu'on nous prépare en
tout cas une chose il ya quelque chose
qui fait plaisir c'est que tout ça sorte
de l'aider câble pour que pour que les
gens le voient le deuxième taux hic
c'est qu'il faut que ce soit bien géré
évidemment de façon à ce que ça rapporte
aussi d'argent s'il faut louvre et tout
ça mais que en contrepartie évidemment
on puisse aller voir d'autres pays qui
en ont besoin et qu'ils ont besoin de
culture et qui sont avides de culture et
qui ont besoin d'aller voir donc je
pense à tous nos pays d'afrique et à ya
beaucoup de pays voilà qui sont en
demande puisqu'il ya des gens qui ont
une fois de la langue française donc
voir des oeuvres magnifiques
voilà où est ce que vous êtes en en tant
que pape avait que votre femme vous
prenez vos deux filles est ce que vous
allez on les musées oui c'est la
première chose que j'ai fait de même à
ma fille est née à deux ans et demi je
l'emmenais je l'emmenais au louvre
justement et je vais emmener toucher les
statuts chose qui est complètement
interdite
oui mais je trouve écoutez je trouve que
les statuts c'est sensuel oui si on met
pas la main dessus
il ya quelque chose qui se passe pas moi
je trouve qu'il ya des types d'art
contemporain je me souviens d'un monde
j'étais allé à beaubourg
il y avait une stature il y avait tout
un il y avait une oeuvre tout en bois
complètement policé et je suis arrivé
j'ai vu art et j'ai mis la main dedans
et je me suis dit tant pis je vais me
faire arracher la tête et le type était
à côté le sculpteur il m'a dit ah bravo
oui j'avais besoin d'eux et je trouve
que c'est
je comprends qu'on ne puisse pas voilà
six à dix millions de les enfants on
voudrait bien savoir comment ils se
prénomment moi je sais mais nos
téléspectateurs ne savent pas lorraine
est tellement je vois la lorraine était
le malheureux c'est la grande qu'elle va
la petite serre tel qu'il ya valorise me
fais pas la blague alors ressortir le
coaching
on va passer à ping pong c'est beaucoup
plus doux voilà ces petites balles de
ping pong c'est l'idée de revenir sur un
article qui vous restent visant à
supporter c'est au contraire fait à
donner mais moi j'ai maintenant j'ai une
bientôt que j'aime beaucoup que
j'affectionne énormément c'est
d'attendre un peu qu'un film sorte de
voir évidemment tout les gens de la
presse classique et puis d'aller sur
internet voir un peu les blogs les blogs
oui parce qu'on veut l'en prend vraiment
plein sa gueule et je trouve ça très
drôle et j'ai eu en espagne je me
souviens d'une certain film kiseki était
sorti là-bas donc comme les gens ne me
connaissent pas alors là est vraiment
ils sont il ya moins de sympathie vous
reprenez et je me souviens d'un des
petits lisez qu'en fait quand je parle
quand je parlais en espagnol ça fume que
je fais qu on aurait dit qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui était en train de
m'écraser les couilles avec avec un
talon ça va fermer une heure d'attenté
pour qu'elle fixe aux pour un film que
j'aie un des premiers films que j'avais
fais où je faisais un type qui venait de
là dans la jungle amazonienne donc
c'était hyper compliqué et donc je
devais avoir sais pas mais carlos saura
sais pas mais non non non non mais bon
non mais le talent on m'a fait penser à
talons almodovar il vous est pas
travaillé vécu non jeu dont je l'aï
rencontré plusieurs fois
on n'a pas su que ce serait naturel que
vous travaillez avec un modèle iphone
mac je regrette mes bas et tout le truc
que j'avais les saigne de caunes sait si
c'est pour lâcher un souteneur pour
aller voir un autre super ça justement
sur ce sujet là est ce que dans les
dents et critique il n'y a pas eu
parfois un petit peu de reliquats de
cette période vous étiez catalogué
comique publions trublion voilà et que
aujourd'hui vous êtes plus est vous le
souhaitez sur des rôles dramatiques
est ce que le passage des deux a prêté
sa pas coincé chez certains il faut le
temps au temps vous savez je crois qu'il
faut beaucoup de temps pour faire un
acteur comique on peut pas arriver
les gens ont besoin de vous connaître et
pour faire
et pour passer du comique au tragique ou
faux tragique ça peut aller vite mais au
drame en tout cas il faut le temps que
les gens acceptent et envie que vous
fassiez une mutation la balle de ping
pong
on sait que sur les blogs il se passe
des choses violents alors passion
d'auteur l'idée de parler de quelqu'un
qui soit vous avez mis nu soit était
important pour vous dans le domaine de
la création a pour moi oui j'ai eu
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas beaucoup
qui s'appelle lon chaney
le chesnay voyons ça j'avoue je ne
connais pas du tout donc je compte sur
vous je vais remettre une bûche dans le
feu donc bah écoutez le chesnay s'éteint
c'est un type que j'ai en fait j'ai la
première émotion que j'ai eu dans ma vie
comme ça au cinéma de minuit vous savez
à wotton avec deux chaînes y avait un
type qui faisait le fantôme de l'opéra
tout le monde se souvient de ce visage
rythme terrifiant et donc j'ai toujours
une image terrible docteur de l'anglais
américain
c'était un acteur américain un homme
qu'on appelait l'homme aux mille visages
c'est un type qui a travaillé souvent
avec tod browning donc les monstres x
voilà c'est un visage extraordinaire le
travail de ce type là est impressionnant
et a décidé alors est ce qu'ils savent
estimé en fait il est mort après le
fantôme de l'opéra parce qu'il a il a
fabriqué ce masque qui est assez
terrifiant et avec les produits qu'il a
utilisée il a chopé un cancer voilà dans
la peau et des morts mais tout ce que ce
type là fait c'est extraordinaire il a
fait des prouesses physiques des choses
absolument démoniaque et on l'appelait
l'homme aux mille visages et moi je me
suis inspiré lui quand je travaillais
avec de caunes à la presse que je
trouvais ça formidable de voir le côté
versatile justement c'était quelqu'un et
avait sur le corps aussi qu'ils étaient
capables de faire par exemple c'est
quand vous faites un une fausse coincé
la jambe derrière pendant des heures
vous n'avez plus de circulation sanguine
et tenir en cul-de-jatte c'est un truc
de fou furieux et lui il a fait des
films entiers
des vidéos qui sont sortis enfin sont
maintenant ses droits de liste moi je ne
touche pas là dessus mais mais le
fantôme de l'opéra
j'espère va garder le plus beau d'accord
avec journal intime heures pour ce
journal intime vous avez une petite
caméra
voilà que vous prenez en main l'idée de
nous emmener dans un dans un endroit où
dans un moment que vous affectionnez
particulièrement est de l'ordre de votre
intimité ou es ce que vous avez envie de
nous emmener josé garcia parce que y'a
un truc que je sais aussi de vous si
vous allez bien voyager dans le luxe
c'est ça de façon voyage et en a envoyé
c'est parce que en fait ça vient du fait
que vous avez voyagé dans des conditions
difficiles
la galicie to work à carreaux 48 heures
de train à côté nous un petit peu comme
on partait la famille garcia à la radio
comment je vais vous filmer parce que
quand je vois votre visage vous est
désespérée en attendant la fête jusqu'à
six apart est bas et goûter à l'époque
et ça existe encore c'est un train qui
existent encore on partait gare
d'austerlitz et puis on arrivé là bas et
puis on avait la bouffe pour 48 heures
vous vouliez en route
c'était assez chaud parce qu'on arrivait
il y avait un changement donc on
descendait jusqu'à et rhône
là encore on est en france la baisse
était un peu précipité la douane et
après ont trôné les tout le monde
prenait les valises et avait à peu près
dix minutes de changement et là tout le
monde se sente est revenu au pays
donc on sortait tout monde sortait les
aime pas nadal et truc à lui les fruits
de les machins et je dois dire que là
pour arriver jusqu'à calais fait c'était
très fort parce que les gendarmes est
carrément dans le couloir c'était
partout tout le monde en chaussettes
donc c'était c'était quand même assez
complet
j'en ai un solide et depuis ce jour la
sauvegarde et c est-à-dire je préfère de
pavillons ou alors j'ai fait des trucs
beaucoup plus route mais pas dans cette
espèce de
de violence et par effet ce qui t'est
pas ce que j'ai fait pendant longtemps
bombay ce sont de beaux souvenirs et de
bons souvenirs c'est les bons souvenirs
oui parce qu'on arrivait on y avait un
mois ouais un mois de vacances bon il ya
de la famille aux cordes oui mais nous
on est une famille d'émigrants d'enfin
tout le monde a été éclatée les premiers
sont partis groupes et de la canne à
sucre à cuba les autres sont partis au
mexique
les autres sont partis en allemagne
enfin la galice est un pays d'une
diaspora garcia c'est tout le monde est
allé entre les galiciens les basques
c'est vraiment des cris on est aux
quatre coins du monde alors voilà on a
un portrait de josé garcia alors avant
que vous ne partiez je voudrais vous
faire un petit cadeau que vous pourrez
partager avec vos filles
voilà voilà le cirque d'hiver sans plomb
guillaume marois voilà chez flammarion
et alors c'est du cirque à l'ancienne
pas très loin d'un certain moment de
freaks de la parade du plus grand
chapiteau du monde a là des choses qui
sait tout ce que j'ai vu ça c'est toute
mon enfance va va là c'est vous voyez ça
vous voyez le type là voilà oui c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu faire ce métier
ouais quelque chose les augustes les
augustes c'est un truc qui me plaît
énormément les augustes voici voilà bah
oui regardez on dirait de koné garcia
voilà deux coups d'oeil arié voilà ce
qu'on en reste
et puis vous savez quand vous avez fait
ça c'est ça qui est génial c'est que
vous êtes toujours à l'abri de vous
prendre au sérieux
oui ce serait peut-être un péché auquel
ça m'étonnerait que ça grandit
voilà à d'autres choses toute la gomme
les comores de la frénésie voilà bon
vous le souhaite tous les péchés c'était
très agréable merci
[Musique]